disease X is a term for a hypothetical
illness one that has not happened and is
currently unknown in the scenario
experts from around the globe are
evaluating what would happen and what we
would need to do in order to prepare for
a virus that could claim up to 20 times
more lives than the covid-19 pandemic in
Davos the disease X scenario took Center
Stage Wednesday you may even call covid
as the first disease
X
and it may happen again the who director
General acknowledges tough lessons were
learned during covid-19 we lost many
people because we couldn't manage them
they could have been saved but there was
no space there was no enough oxygen so
how can you have a system that can
expand when the need comes this
bioethics professor says the pandemic
showed us how one disease absorbing all
available resources can lead to other
health issues falling through the cracks
cancer diagnosis did not take place
which very severe consequences for the
people that were affected shling says
there are also ethical questions to
consider when preparing for the next big
Health Emergency do we try to limit the
number of of lives that we lose or do we
limit the number of Life years that we
lose to what extent should we be
concerned about Equity considerations
are we just concerned about health
outcomes he cautions Canada is not ready
we will be wholly unprepared for this
because we under resource we don't have
the staff we don't have the available so
it would be a major problem obviously
anything happening is a matter of when
not if Katherine Ward Global News